okay let's play nick sev
ooh okay i assume
i assume you want to you want me to be
black
so i'm in the boards and rematch i'll
flip the color
unless you really want to challenge and
play black
oh maybe i'm playing the skits i don't
know how to say your name
too many consonants none of the fouls
this is brutal white too so
some it's it's it's fun though like to
try and survive these positions kind of
but uh i kind of feel like a punching
bag
opponent even took away my rooks or
replaced them with bishops at least i
have the long diagonals
so how much am i down i'm down i'm down
28.
i've done 28 things
i'm trying to like draft a strategy
what's the best move here
i'm not getting mated immediately so
that's a good thing
i want to play d4
i can't even i can't play i can't play
this because i lose a bishop
i'm thinking a6 or c6
but a6 doesn't even prepare b5
maybe h6 also there's d
no d5 is pinned wow let's play h6
okay three plus two maybe i can use time
to my advantage v hall says gg
after one move
let's fight i mean at least i have
pieces to work with it's not like i
don't have any pieces
i just so there's a few strategies i
really have to avoid trades
i'm gonna try and like fork as many
things as possible
but even if i lose pawns and there's
open files i have no rooks to
to exploit open files
a6 so i'm threatening the double for
that i don't want to give my opponent
any easy decisions
opponent's bullet rating is a bit lower
okay so
my my main compensation is a form of
rating points
of 11 1150 points
rating points of compensation don't
think that compensates for being down
28 uh 28 points of material
um i'm thinking c6 here actually oh c6
bishop a5 traps my queen
that's brutal
all right let's do it let's win some
stuff
and after i'm assuming like it's going
to take twice somehow and then i'll have
bishop a6
or knight a6 or even bishop b7
like some of these ideas like having two
lights for bishops
i don't see right away but this is a
nice battery
interesting okay let's take
okay now i'm only down 25. i want a
whole a whole bishop
white's not even winning a pawn for it
that's a small victory that's like
finding a quarter
on the side of the road
do i play g5 the g5
idea double um the double fiance battery
let's do it
hmm so white's doing the same thing
white probably has like some
some love for for symmetry like this
move's coming
and maybe this move
so i i found another quarter i'm only
down 22.
i'm up a lot of time though wow white's
so generous
i wonder if like my opponent's thought
process is that
uh they can afford to just sack
minor pieces for pawns because there's
like white has so many minor pieces
and at this point they're still kind of
just in the way of each other
i'll play e6
okay
like the biggest principle is don't
trade i'll play 97 knight g6
this is almost mate but then i just take
yeah if i play safe chests and i'll i'll
try and play
safe chest and quick chest
there's not much space to work with
d6 like d697
i'm trying to work with what i have
yeah this is a kind of decision moment
because i can just close down the
position
i think that makes the most sense
it's getting very long time it'll be
tragic if white just flags
avoid sacking more minor pieces
i can't complain with that
i have not lost a a single minor piece
okay it feels like christmas plus
birthday plus hanukkah
what other days of the year do people
give gifts oh
if i take i don't want to trade queens
like the queen is how i end up winning
this game
if that's even possible
but if i've i mean if i don't take that
i'm losing this pawn
so i think it looks really bad but i'm
going to play bishop e7 and if knight
takes i play king f8
bishop takes also possible
my time is low too
i was like on the flag white was very
close to flagging there
oh okay that's nice
play this okay
oh it's only two second increments
[Music]
okay coming back oh white could have
taken my queen
i didn't even realize that
okay
wow opponent was very generous to me
but also like just got very long time
and probably freaked out
yeah this is this is a bad move on my
part
like white's still up like 12
12 things okay
yeah why was maybe like slightly nervous
too
whoa it's jared jay i made a challenge
where are two rooks trapped in opposing
pawn diamonds like i said the
other day other day yeah i hope you play
it
interesting well i'm following kind of
this uh
this list of of things so i just played
never played before sub
now i'm going to play the highest rated
i'll keep an eye out for that
oh xkxg says
first time playing on stream scared me
ah
i remember like i can relate to that
like back in the day
like like when i would play gms
i would get nervous just have to take a
deep breath just focus on
i'm trying to play good moves